on me donne la fin soit payé un festin
comme on aime ce qui est vain et
secondaire je te retrouves de prix la
vie enfin chrome os donne la paire de
gemmes tories
me donne le froid que j'aime la flamme
porter j'aime ma terre pour modèle les
cris les combats permanent pour l'hévéa
pas vous
[Musique]
à consommer
j'ai voulu
merci pour tours 2
mon envie
ap
madonna
non
oubliée
ça je dois reconnaître que c'est un
certain kif que de commencer et
d'arriver sur scène avec johnny hallyday
perso ça fait assez plaisir je vous
disais juste avant que john il commence
à chanter
quel type dans vie vous avez envie
d'avoir quel type d'environ n'a envie de
construire et quel type dans vie on
souhaite faire partager et donner aux
autres alors il yal'envie convient
d'entendre écrite par goldman et dans la
bouche de johnny qu'on connaît tous ce
qui fait qui apporte la lumière c'est ce
qu'il y a des mots forts dans ce qui
dans ce qu'ils chantent
et puis il ya ce type dans villa je vais
vous laisser la découvrir c'est un
professeur du 19e siècle qui a écrit ça
et qui donne une vision de l'envy
maladive la description qui fait sur le
type de maladie qu'on risque d'avoir et
que portent en eux les gens envieux je
sais pas mes enfants je sais pas
vraiment celle que j'ai envie d'avoir
c'est pas vraiment celle que j'aurais
envie de partager et pourtant pourtant
je suis certain qu'on a tous à un moment
donné ont eu une certaine forme dans vie
alors quoi comme type dans vie ben quand
on a été enfant quand j'ai été enfant il
m'est arrivé
en plus j'étais fils unique dont c'est
compliqué je le suis toujours dire c'est
compliqué mais il nous arrive de
regarder le jouet du voisin en disant ah
ouais ok d'accord c'est pas la même
chose
c'est une première forme dans vie un peu
plus tard au lycée
ben moi j'ai été assez envieux de 3 mais
qui réussissait à sortir avec des filles
qui étaient quand même super jolie et
avec qui j'avais pris des bons râteau et
puis après j'ai commencé à bosser et je
bossais dans une agence de communication
et je voyais bien qu'il y avait des gens
qui allaient plus vite que moi sur
certains sujets donc forcément on a
aussi ses envies la saison villas c'est
quoi finalement cédé en vie qui nous
bloque c'est des envies qui nous arrête
en tout cas moi elles m'ont arrêté mois
elles m'ont bloqué j'ai toujours eu la
chance en revanche de faire le métier
dont j'ai toujours rêvé petit mais pour
plein de raisons
j'avais envie de faire de la pub ça me
paraissait être un truc extraordinaire
avec un peu de recul ça l'est toujours
pas si je vais même enthousiasme
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas c'est
quelque chose et c'est un métier qui
repose sur l'envi si vous arrivez chez
un gros client et voulait lui vendre
quelque chose que vous arrivez les pieds
en dedans
la tête en bas et ces garanties qui vous
achètera rien si en revanche pendant la
présentation vous faites vous lui faites
partager un peu de l'envi un peu de
cette envie là moi je me suis rendu
compte que c'était une forme de pouvoir
que c'était quelque chose qui était
assez magique mais ça reste une envie
finalement assez égoïste parce que c'est
la mienne je la partage avec un petit
nombre de personnes
mais ça s'arrête là et l'âge venant
l'expérience venant les enfants
grandissant je me suis rendu compte
surtout que ce qui était important
c'était de faire que cette envie on la
transforme en une énergie formidable et
qu'on en fasse quelque chose qu'on
puisse partager avec les autres
c'est un peu comme un carburant vous
mettez dans un moteur tout d'un coup ça
fait un moteur à explosion et il se
passe quelque chose et ça c'est ce qui
me paraissait être le plus le plus
frappant le plus engageants qui donnait
envie de faire quelque chose un matin
j'ai discuté avec anne des enfants et
qui avait 12 13 ans à l'époque et qui me
dit ah tu sais pas mais j'ai un copain à
l'école tous les soirs il s'endort en
parlant à son téléphone comme il peut
parler à son téléphone ça n'existe pas
d'ici là l'application siri ge pas si
vous connaissez et son téléphone lui
répond et je lui dis je fais un métier
qui s'appelle la communication on rentre
dans une époque aujourd'hui où on parle
à son téléphone on parle plus à son
voisin et vous avez tous fait j'imagine
ce constat là c'est qu'on n'a jamais été
aussi connectés les uns aux autres et
pourtant on n'a jamais autant garder le
pied quand on marche dans la rue
alors certes et des crottes de chien
mais c'est pas que la cause de ça c'est
juste que tout d'un coup un regard peut
devenir une agression et je me suis dit
d'autres se disent d'autres choses en se
rasant le matin je me suis dit et si et
si non redonner envie aux gens de
prendre le risque d'une conversation
j'ai créé un truc on m'a regardé avec
des yeux ronds comme des billes faisant
complètement fou j'ai créé le festival
des conversations il festival des
conversations c'est quoi c'est donner
envie aux gens de venir à un moment
donné partager un sujet de conversation
quel qu'il soit c'est ouvert à tout le
monde les gens viennent et ce que je
demande aux gens c'est venez vous mêler
à nos conversations apportez votre
pierre votre brique est aujourd'hui le
festival il existe dans cette forme là
c'est à dire que il ya une journée 16
avril c'est la journée de la
conversation et dans cette forme là il
existe un peu partout dans le monde
on a plein de petits festivals des
conversations qui sont nés il ya eu çà
existe à new york ça existe à londres ça
existe au maroc
c'est pour moi quelque chose d'important
que de voir des gens s'emparer de ce
sujet qui est la conversation
hormis grèce est anodin ça change pas
fondamentalement le monde et ça fait pas
vraiment bougé
je suis d'accord mais simplement il ya
une gourmandise dans la conversation
il ya une espèce de plaisir dans la
conversation et on est un époque on est
dans un monde où on a devant nous des
centaines de nouvelles fenêtres qui
existe qui permet de converser
les réseaux sociaux permettent de
converser et les jeux vidéos permettent
de convertir de converser moi j'ai
travaillé beaucoup sur les jeux vidéo et
on s'est rendu compte que des gens qui
jouent à des jeux comme world of
warcraft par exemple est bien la
première chose qu'ils font quand ils ont
créé leur ligue
c'est de vouloir se retrouver en vrai
pour parler avec les gens avec qui ils
sont et ça pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'étonnant c'est à dire que nous avons
c'est fenêtre de conversation et on sait
pas forcément bien s'en servir
donc un des enjeux pour moi c'est
vraiment de réussir à faire en sorte que
l'on prenne conscience qu'on doit plus
est esclave de ces objets là et qu'on
doit s'en servir comme des moyens
d'aller plus loin et d'aller vers les
autres
converser ça veut dire ne plus rien plus
ne dire que aller avec faire avec
partage à une envie c'est ça c'est faire
en sorte qu'à un moment donné on donne à
quelque quelque chose à l'autre et que
l'autre vous renvoie quelque chose et
puis festival il a évolué par l'état
leur de gourmandise de conversation il
ya un moment qui est extraordinaire pour
une conversation s'est préparé un repas
et donc ayant travaillé dans des
quartiers qu'ils étaient des quartiers
un peu compliqué avec des communautés
qui ne se parlaient pas j'ai décidé de
créer le festival des cuisines
populaires
le festival de cuisine populaire ça
donne ce genre de sourire la cedh ainsi
d'installer pendant trois quatre jours
en pied d'immeuble dans des quartiers
vraiment compliqué des gens et de dire
voilà on va ensemble partager un repas a
remis tout à la semoule tu l'as fait
comme sa toile m'a fait tu le fais comme
ça toi ton couscous ya sept dents et
cetera etc
et c'est ça je veux qu'on arrive à faire
et qui a donné naissance et quelques
années à la création de blanzay but
c'est de faire en sorte que l'on
réussisse à faire avec à faire les uns
avec les autres
je suis là c'est quand on me dit
aujourd'hui le vivre ensemble c'est
important oui bien sûr mais on le subit
le vivre ensemble
ce qui est important c'est de faire avec
c'est de faire pour les autres c'est de
partager un certain nombre de choses
un matin j'allais en rendez vous chez un
de mes clients et j'étais un peu en
avance j'achète un journal et je tombe
sur une chronique qui était signée
alexandre jardin et qui s'appelait
colère et ils disaient j'en ai assez
j'en ai assez de ce monde on dit aux
gens que le plus beau jour de leur vie
c'est le jour ils partent à la retraite
j'en ai assez qu'on dise et qu'on de le
résume la vie de la société française
uniquement au fil d'info de bfm tv
honnêtement quand vous regardez ça vous
dit qu'on est dans un pays foutu on s'en
sortira jamais et bien tout cet article
tourné autour de ça est il terminé en
disant une chose et si on agissait
et si on faisait qu'on prenait en main
notre destin pour faire bouger les
choses
j'ai fait une chose que je n'avais
jamais fait jusqu'à présent
pas sûr de recommencer que je vais
envoyer un mail en lui disant on se
connaissait pas ce qu'on avait travaillé
ensemble sur le festival des
conversations j'ai envoyé un mail en
disant vous faites des choses dans votre
coin
moi j'en fais dans bien et si on les
faisait ensemble et à ma grande surprise
le lendemain il m'a appelée une vie on
prend un café
bon on est allé prendre un café on a
passé une heure ensemble sur partie de
l'an 10 ans ce mec est complètement sain
très brillant mais centré qu'est ce
qu'il a fait pendant le leurre qu'on a
passé ensemble
il m'a fait partager son envie il m'a
fait partager ce moment de dire mais
effectivement vous fait des choses
chacun dans notre coin
et si à un moment donné on unit c'est
mon envie si à un moment donné on
munissez nos façons de travailler et
d'avancer ensemble pour faire bouger les
choses et si on pouvait réussir à faire
un truc qui peut paraître dingue c'est
de faire bouger la société
arrêtez de râler arrêter de se dire
c'est foutu on peut rien y faire
on est tous une part de responsabilité
de la société dans lequel on vit
aujourd'hui et à chacun à son niveau
peut faire quelque chose donc on a lancé
il ya trois ans maintenant un mouvement
qui s'appelle bleu-blanc zèbres quand on
a démarré on était 15
on n'avait pas un sou on n'avait aucun
moyen j'avais juste la chance d'avoir un
porte parole qui est alexandre qui quand
il appelle une chaîne de télé ou un
média
généralement on lui ouvre les portes et
on a démarré ma chaussure j'étais
hommage était en algérie pour mon boulot
et je recevais les mails des gens avant
qu'ils aient son émission de télé sur
france 2 et je voyais bien la connexion
était pas terrible mais je vais bien que
les mais l'arrêté pas d'arriver et il y
avait des tas de gens qui partout en
france disait moi je fais ça moi je fais
ça maj rec tels problèmes de la société
parce que notre message il était simple
c'était de dire vous réunissez un
problème vous réglez apprennent la
société française peu importe la
structure que vous ayez vous soyez une
association une entreprise un élu local
peu importe parce que je voulais qu'on
règle votre problème vous viger de
savoir quelle est la structure qui est
en face de vous ce que vous voulez c'est
qu'on agisse qu'on fasse quelque chose
et on a embarqué des gens dont on a
découvert qu'ils étaient excessivement
seul je suis sûr que dans la saga des
tas de gens qui s'ils travaillent dans
des assauts connaît des entreprises qui
ont trouvé des façons de régler une
partie de la solution française
ce qu'on sait c'est que depuis trois ans
maintenant où on arpente les territoires
avec alexandre où on va partout vraiment
majoritairement et peut-être même dans
leur intégralité des problèmes de la
société française ont tous trouvé une
solution
la seule chose c'est qu'elle sont isolés
la seule chose c'est qu'encore une fois
vous ne les verrez jamais dans les
médias classiques tels qu'on les connaît
je refaire un coup sur bfm et itélé mais
vous les verrez pas dans la presse
quotidienne régionale de temps raconte
un certain nombre de choses mais ne fait
que survoler
nous ce qu'on veut c'est que
profondément ses solutions qui existent
qui règle les sept fractures de la
société tels qu'on les a identifiés qui
sont le logement le chômage l'emploi
l'éducation le fer avec la fraternité
etc
toutes ces actions là puissent se
partager et qu'on réunisse des gens et
concret ce qu'on appelle des parcours
c'est à dire qu'on soit capable de
régler quand une fois pas tout mais un
bond de l'awb des problèmes de la
société française
il ya une phrase de mère teresa que
j'aime beaucoup qui dit que tout ce
qu'on peut faire peut paraître minuscule
ça peut être une goutte d'eau dans
l'océan mais l'océan on n'aura plus
jamais le même goût et ça je suis
convaincu de sa c'est à dire que on a
tous en main cette capacité à faire
bouger les choses allaient faire avancer
à faire changer et c'est cette énergie
là cette envie là qu'aujourd'hui on
partage avec alex en est avec 300
actions qui sont sur la plateforme plus
de 70 territoire dans lequel on est
présents qui vont de communes dans la
banlieue de dijon de 200 personnes à la
région paca avec 3 millions d'habitants
et demain la région des hautes francs
et la bourgogne puisque je suis en est
en train de discuter avec la bourgogne
lancement donc on est vraiment sur des
modèles qui montre que la société civile
dont on parle c'est à dire nous tous
pouvons nous engager et pourront faire
bouger les choses
quand on a créé le site de blanc zèbres
alexandre il faut qu'on donne la
possibilité aux gens de pouvoir
s'engager etc et on a tourné on a
cherché et puis un jour il a il
m'appelle il disait j'ai trouvé on va
donner aux gens la possibilité de
s'engager une minute une heure ou un
jour il avait oublié de dire c'est qu'on
pouvait aussi s'engager pour la vie mais
ça ma femme s'en est rendu compte depuis
en revanche s'engage et une minutes une
heure ou un jour c'est tout simple une
minute c'est quoi on a tous autour de
soi des gens qui avons un compte
facebook une un compte twitter etc
c'est simplement de dire j'aime ou je
fais connaître à l'action une minute pas
beaucoup où j'ai autour de moi telle
chose une heure c'est j'habite dans tel
quartier
je sais qu'il ya une association ou une
entreprise qui règle un problème de coût
de wet de covoiturage qui règlent
apprennent de lecture qui règle un
problème de retour à l'emploi etc
je veux vous faire connaître cette
action est une heure c'est de dire bah
voila moi j'habite dans tel quartier
dans telle rue et j'ai envie de faire ce
qu'on appelle un café de zèbres c'est là
que j'ai envie d'avoir des gens qui vont
se réunir autour de nous et qui vont
s'engager et qui vont simplement
partager à un moment donné cette valeur
commune qui pour moi est la chose la
plus importante dans notre devise
républicaine c'est la fraternité c'est
la seule sur lequel en plus on puisse
directement la jirs ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est faire avec et on
est tous des acteurs de cette fraternité
la voilà c'était ça un petit peu
l'histoire de deux d'edf que j'avais
envie de partager avec vous et
finalement aujourd'hui être en vie avoir
envie c'est avoir envie de partager ses
avoir envie de faire avec ces avoir
envie de communiquer et c'est avoir
envie d'être un peu bousculée parce que
les autres nous amène en face et un
dernier point parce qu'on me pose
souvent la question qu'est ce que ça
veut dire que bleu blanc zèbres pourquoi
le zèbre alors je vous confier trois
secrets le z pourquoi parce que c'est
d'abord parce que ça correspond aux
livres qu'alexandre et puis écrire
c'était assez basique deuxième élément
c'est que lozère est un animal qui ne se
dresse pas vous ne verrez jamais aucun
zèbres dans un cirque
jamais il ya eu des expériences
malheureuses au moment de la deuxième
guerre mondiale ou d après des
bombardements alliés sur l'allemagne et
des villes allemandes qui avaient essayé
d'utiliser des aides qu'ils étaient dans
des eaux pour tracter des autobus pas
été très brillant est ce que vous savez
pourquoi les zèbres sont rayés des
zèbres sont rayés pour éviter d'être
piqués par la mouche tsé tsé
donc ça veut dire qu'on nous endormir à
jamais
[Applaudissements]